when you form the police
you have your drummer your guitar player
was a different dude at first right what
was that guy he was of course a good guy
called Henry padovani why did he quit
the band or did you throw him out we
couldn't really play but he looked great
he had a good look he had like leather
pants and uh the best songs yeah the
best
yeah you look great so okay we formed
the band the police is this the first
time you attempt to write your own songs
oh no no I've been writing my songs
since I was a kid uh I don't know why I
had this idea maybe the Beatles yeah of
course uh gave me that that idea that I
could write songs I'm not sure how good
they were but the age of 10 11 I was
writing stuff the rest of the police
guys they wait for you to write these
songs they do do they start to get
resentful that you're the writer that
you're the front man yeah I was like a
cuckoo in the nest you know they didn't
really know what they were taking on
yeah because you become more and more
important because you're the songwriter
I'm the singer I'm the songwriter and
I'd had many years of experience as a
songwriter so I had a whole catalog of
songs that I'd never used in the public
domain if you like the synchronicity
album was the last album the police
recorded together is that correct that's
true and you did your last tour together
did the record company think that you
guys and did your management everything
think you guys were out of your minds to
break up at that point because this
album a synchronicity sold a lot of
albums you were on top of the world that
decision to do a tour and then break up
was that your decision alone
we didn't officially break up how it
right you're still together I just
thought it was time that I exercised my
right to make a solo album as the others
had done right and then that was a
massive hit right and so I went hang on
a minute yeah well there is a certain
Liberation in being a solo artist right
maybe it was maybe when you're a younger
man you needed a family a musical family
because you didn't have a family growing
up your parents were divorced yeah
that's true and I'm very grateful for
that musical family they're a great band
an extremely fond of them and respect
them and love them and grateful for them
right but I needed to spread my wings
you know I needed a different uh
set of colors to work with gives you
some Freedom artistically right to go in
a different direction well you know a
band has a certain sound yeah and it's
kind of limiting it's wonderful but it's
limiting
foreign